Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Bonne année à toutes et à tous !
J'espère
que vous avez passé un bon réveillon !
Ici, on a fait une de ces fêtes.
Du coup,
il y en a
qui ont un peu la gueule de bois.
Bon, de mon côté, ça va.
J'ai encore les idées claires.
Enfin, j'espère.
Pour vous expliquer d'où vient
cette fameuse gueule de bois
qui nous tombe dessus,
les lendemains de soirées
un peu trop arrosées
et comment on peut y remédier ?
Ça, je veux bien que tu m'expliques.
Cheers !
C'est de l'eau.
Pas de problème.
Non, c'est par là.
Oh là là.
Le chantier.
C'est ici qu'on a fait la fête.
Bon, je vous rassure,
on était nombreux
et on a consommé avec modération.
Enfin, presque tout le monde.
Juste un peu pompette.
Heureusement, il a dormi à la maison.
D'ailleurs, il a dû se réveiller
avec une de ces gueules de bois.
Cela dit, pas la peine de faire des excès.
Moi même, ce matin,
je ne suis pas complètement dans mon
assiette.
En fait, 4 verres de vin
peuvent suffire
à donner la gueule de bois.
Parfois moins.
C'est variable en fonction des individus,
selon le sexe, la masse corporelle
ou bien les habitudes de consommation.
Celui ou celle qui consomme
plus régulièrement, sans faire d'excès
bien sûr, est moins exposé
que celui ou celle
qui ne boit que très rarement.
Ouf !
L'expression "gueule de bois"
daterait du XVIIIᵉ siècle.
À l'époque, avoir la gueule de bois
signifiait avoir la gueule, c'est à dire
la bouche sèche comme du bois,
ce qui arrive souvent
après une nuit de fête.
Elle a ensuite évolué
pour décrire l'ensemble des symptômes
que l'on associe à une surconsommation
d'alcool.
Certains parlent
d'intoxication alcoolique.
Les médecins préfèrent parler de veisalgie.
Le mot vient du norvégien "kveis",
qui veut dire inconfort,
et du grec "algia",
qui signifie douleur.
Je me demande comment il fait
pour soutenir un truc comme ça,
un jour pareil...
Moi aussi.
La gueule de bois
peut se manifester
de différentes manières :
fatigue, maux de tête, douleurs au niveau des yeux.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Cette sensation désagréable
quand on tourne les yeux
sur le côté.
Ça fait mal...
D'autres ont la gorge sèche, tremblent
et il y en a même
qui ont des trous de mémoire.
On y reviendra un peu plus tard.
Les premiers signes apparaissent
en moyenne
8 à 16h après la consommation d'alcool.
À ce moment-là, on est dans le pâté,
comme on dit.
C'est en général au bout de 24h que la sensation de mal-être
atteint son paroxysme.
Curieusement, au moment
où le taux d'alcoolémie
est déjà retombé à 0.
Hey, la petite caméra
aussi était là hier soir.
Maintenant,
nous allons essayer de comprendre
ce qui nous arrive
lorsque nous sommes victimes
de la gueule de bois.
Et pour cela, je propose d'aller
faire un tour à l'intérieur
de notre organisme.
Direction le foie !
Quand on absorbe de l'alcool.
Le foie est notre meilleur allié.
Il est capable de métaboliser,
transformer si vous préférez,
95% de l'alcool que nous ingérons.
Le reste est éliminé par la sueur,
l'urine ou l'air que nous expirons.
Mais ce travail lui demande
un gros effort.
Si notre consommation
est trop importante et trop rapide.
Le foie ne peut plus assurer sa fonction.
Il se trouve en suractivation,
la machine ne fonctionne plus
correctement.
L'éthanol contenu dans le foie
est dégradé sous forme d'acétaldéhyde .
Il s'agit d'un composé chimique qui provoque une intoxication.
À des concentrations
trop importantes,
l'acétaldéhyde agit comme un poison.
Il est responsable
d'une partie des symptômes
que l'on ressent quand on a
la gueule de bois :
les nausées, la tachycardie et même
des rougeurs sur le visage.
Ouf !
De ce côté là, rien à signaler.
Mais avant d'être métabolisé par le foie,
l'alcool
passe préalablement par l'estomac.
Et ces deux-là ne font pas bon ménage.
À petites doses,
un verre de vin comme celui-ci...
Beurk... pfff
ne pose aucun problème à notre estomac.
Mais une consommation excessive
peut entraîner la libération
d'acides gastriques qui vont irriter
la muqueuse de cet organe.
Alors ce n'est pas très grave,
mais dans certains cas,
ça peut aller jusqu'à l'inflammation
de la muqueuse gastrique.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle la gastrite alcoolique.
Elle est aussi responsable des nausées
que l'on ressent
les lendemains de fête, de ballonnements,
de contractions douloureuses
qui peuvent aller
jusqu'aux vomissements.
Là, il faut faire attention
parce que la gastrite alcoolique
peut durer
même une fois la gueule de bois terminée.
Dans ce cas,
il vaut mieux consulter un médecin.
Alors vous l'avez sûrement remarqué
depuis le début de la vidéo,
il y en a un qui n'arrête
pas de boire de l'eau.
Normal, il est déshydraté.
Déshydraté ?
Moi ? Avec tout ce que j'ai bu ?
Je sais, c'est un peu contre intuitif.
Pour comprendre,
il faut regarder du côté du cerveau.
En temps normal,
celui-ci sécrète
une hormone antidiurétique
appelée vasopressive.
Son rôle est d'envoyer
des signaux aux reins afin
qu'ils retiennent
l'eau en quantité suffisante
pour leur bon fonctionnement.
Mais il se trouve que l'alcool bloque
la libération de cette hormone.
Du coup, l'organisme
utilise l'eau à volonté
pour éliminer l'alcool.
Résultat on fait pipi plus souvent
et on se déshydrate.
Ce phénomène explique aussi
pourquoi les gens qui ont
la gueule de bois ont souvent la bouche
pâteuse, la bouche sèche.
Vous vous souvenez ?
Bouche sèche... gueule de bois.
La déshydratation
est également à l'origine de tout
un tas d'autres désagréments,
comme les maux de tête, la fatigue,
mais aussi l'altération de la mémoire.
Il n'est pas rare
que certains souvenirs de la veille
s'effacent tout simplement.
Qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de mes lunettes ?
Ben, tu les as sur ton nez.
Dans les cas extrêmes,
certaines personnes connaissent
même de véritables black out.
Ils sont incapables de se souvenir
de ce qu'ils ont fait la veille
et parfois de l'endroit
où ils se trouvaient.
Alors évidemment, la question
que tout le monde se pose, c'est...
Existe-t-il un moyen
pour éviter la gueule de bois
un lendemain de fête ?
J'aimerais tellement vous dire oui.
Malheureusement,
il n'y a pas de remède miracle.
Bon, j'ai quand même quelques petits conseils
à vous donner pour limiter les dégâts.
D'abord, consommez avec modération.
Évitez de consommer le ventre vide.
Ensuite, consommez lentement,
n'enchainez pas les boissons alcoolisées.
Faites des pauses agrémentées
de plusieurs verres d'eau.
Lors du traditionnel
repas de famille du 1ᵉʳ janvier,
évitez le saumon fumé et le foie gras.
Ce sont des matières grasses
qui obligerait votre foie
à faire des heures supplémentaires.
Idem pour le café
et tous les aliments acides
comme le jus d'orange ou le chocolat.
Évitez-les, là encore, pour préserver votre foie.
Optez plutôt pour des pommes
ou des bananes,
des laitages allégés en matières grasses
ou des protéines maigres
comme la viande blanche.
Et pour lutter contre la déshydratation,
rien de tel que de l'eau
et un bon bouillon de légumes, bien chaud.
En plus de vous réhydrater,
il va faciliter la digestion.
Allez,
un dernier petit conseil pour la route.
Ne prenez surtout pas le volant.
Si vous avez la gueule de bois,
même si votre taux d'alcoolémie
est retombé à 0.
Votre corps ne s'est pas
remis de la soirée de la veille,
particulièrement votre cerveau.
Des chercheurs de l'université
de Bath, au Royaume-Uni,
ont démontré que la concentration,
les réflexes et la coordination
des mouvements
restaient altérés
pendant la gueule de bois.
Alors prudence.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout.
J'espère que ces quelques conseils
vous seront utiles
pour vos prochaines soirées
et pour ne rien rater de cette belle
année 2023 qui commence.
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner.
Encore une fois, chers
Épicurieuses et Épicurieux,
je vous souhaite
une très bonne année.